connecticut opera singer who rammed
through mar-a-lago security blockade and
narrowly escaped secret service bullets
in january 2020 is found not guilty by
reason of insanity
hannah romhild 32 was found not guilty
by reason of insanity on tuesday her
attorney said she had a history of
mental illness and had stopped taking
her medication before she drove through
the
mar-a-lago security blockade she must
undergo psychiatric treatment and
counseling and take medications with
monthly blood tests to confirm
compliance
she pulled her rented jeep into the
parking lot of the breakers a luxury
hotel and began dancing on her car and
making obscene gestures she led police
on a dangerous chase where police and
secret service fired at her vehicle as
she swerved checkpoints she then drove
the airport to pick up her mother okay
before being arrested at a nearby motel
so i don't know if this lady was
actually motivated by anything political
but seeing stories like this i have to
wonder
i was i was on twitter and i saw some
people making posts about how their
therapist had said this that or
otherwise and i thought to myself it's
kind of weird that all of these like
democrat personalities have therapists
right
is there something to this that people
with trump derangement syndrome
they don't
they need someone to help them think
properly be it or maybe a medication on
them think properly or
i think when you live in the
military-industrial complex in the
empire the heart of the empire it's hard
not to go crazy i particularly when i
lived in la for like eight nine years i
thought i needed a therapist it wasn't
until i started speaking my mind on the
internet fluidly daily monday through
friday that i stopped feeling the need
to look outside for help because i'm
finding it here within myself or at
least in this table conversation yeah if
you live in major city areas the
likelihood of you having mental health
issues actually goes up dramatically
compared to the suburbs but uh with this
particular story who said it doesn't pay
to be crazy right i mean she got off had
all of her charges dropped but on a
serious note there is a mental health
crisis that this country is dealing with
that is getting worse by the day and
there has been a lot of circumstantial
evidence suggesting that it's because of
social media use again circumstantial
evidence correlation does not prove
causation but i i think it's fair to say
a lot of people are losing their marbles
losing their minds there's a lot of
doctors easily prescribing ssris easily
prescribing
addictive painkillers to individuals
that have an effect on their life you
want early treatment for for covet no no
no no pain kills ssris poop you're gonna
get it right away which is absolutely uh
crazy with how our medical institution
is run today dana white brought that up
yeah you know he's at a press conference
he was like i bet i can get these pain
pills before i get monoclonal antibodies
but uh the other thing too is we were
talking about with cnn when when i think
it was like brian stelter he was like
the trauma of january 6th the
journalists trauma
um like they're sitting in an
air-conditioned
building in new york city they're
nowhere near the capital and they're
experiencing trauma
well look at this story from vox back in
2021 people are not okay the mental
health impact of the trump era yo i got
a solution it's not therapy it's not
medication it's turning off the computer
it's turning off the monitor screen and
going in like i don't know smelling
flowers or something turn off the boob
tube yeah like turn off the tv turn off
the fear-mongering when you look at what
the corporate media feeds into people's
minds it is absolute trash and garbage
it is some of the most destructive
negative low vibrational thinking that
you could have in your existence jammed
down your throat by dr fauci by anderson
cooper by all these smear merchants
saying breaking news fear-mongering
you're supposed to be afraid because of
this today you're supposed to give up
your rights because of this today you're
supposed to live in your pod eat the
bugs be in the metaverse because it is
good for you and then people are
following those orders doing what
they're told and they're learning that
they're they're miserable gee i wonder
why well i don't think there's anything
wrong with therapy whatsoever i think
and this might be a controversial
opinion but i don't think there's
anything even wrong with being emotional
i know there's a big backlash against
the left because they're so emotional i
would argue they are emotional but it's
unmitigated reactive emotion being human
you're gonna have emotions so i think
the issue here is really that people
don't have a container to hold their
emotions and therefore they act out in
ways like this you end up with chaos all
over the place in fact i think the
solution to that is to be more
comfortable with emotion to be able to
able to better feel it and hold space
for yourself and of course others but i
think it's people's inability to do that
that leads to this
chaos over emotional reaction like um
pharmaceutical drugs like what do you
pinpoint is the the reason why people
are having a difficult time with their
emotions right now i mean i think people
have always struggled with emotions like
to be human is to suffer and this is
sort of a buddhist belief but i mean who
hasn't suffered who hasn't felt
difficult emotions i think it's people's
tendency to want to avoid the discomfort
by say taking pills and i'm not saying
it's never appropriate to take pills if
you have a mental health condition i
don't know your experience i don't know
why you would be on them but i think
obviously they're over prescribed and i
think that's ultimately an attempt by
people and their providers to just numb
it out instead of just building the
inner resources to be able to sit with
it and there's a ton of stuff in our
society that incentivizes avoiding
feeling avoiding expressing your
emotions avoiding dealing with any kind
of hardship or any kind of hard truth
realities as they're giving everyone
medals as they're congratulating
everyone and and denying them the basic
truth of this world that it is difficult
it is hard it's not fair life will never
be fair but these people are told it's
always going to be fair everything's
going to be fine you're going to get a
trophy just by participating and they're
realizing holy crap the real world
doesn't work that way they're having a
big reality check they don't know how to
deal with those emotions they go online
and they they're consumed by the
algorithms that control them or by other
adult content especially young children
are doing this that they shouldn't be
watching that rewires their brain to be
working in such negative horrible ways
that creates destructive relationships
and disharmony in people's personal
lives i think
a lot of people over the past seven
years you know since the start of the
media's obsession with trump have been
dealing with an ever-shifting news
landscape that keeps changing its
opinions and mocking people when they
don't know exactly what the new
narrative is so if you take a look at
like i don't know joe biden comes out
and he says
if you get the vaccine this is joe biden
saying this it's going to stop the
spread of covet paraphrasing now that's
not true today they say it will reduce
the severity of symptoms but there's a
major shift so if you're somebody who's
like i don't know you're uh
you're an accountant you know you don't
watch the news all day every day you see
this story and you're like okay i see
the president speaking
the news changes
and then you see the news again a week
later and it's it's a 180 from where
they were and now you're sitting there
saying like has anyone noticed this
you're thinking to yourself something
doesn't make sense and then you go to
someone or you go online and you post
like this seems strange to me and what
happens they attack you for it you get
attacked you get insulted you get
smeared i think this is driving people
insane it's making people insane you
look at the news about trump and the
media lies every single day and it's
escalating and getting worse and worse
and all the lies and they've still been
lying about the guy even though it's
been you know a year or a long a little
bit longer than a year since he was in
the office but just about a year since
he was in office
they keep lying
but you can't have these these different
things be true at the same time
but if you try and speak out you'll be
attacked for it seems like there's three
types of insanity there's the people
that believe that the narrative shifting
without questioning it that's a type of
insanity just going with the flow then
there's the people that question the
change in the narrative and call it out
and get
called insane and then they start to go
insane because they're like why am i
being attacked for questioning this then
there's the people that see it all and
think it's all crazy those people are
just considered insane
that's kind of where i'm at anyway i
mean i i tweet about this stuff and i
actually have like prominent politically
homeless journalists
uh responding to me saying like well the
new narrative is is is this
you know particularly talking about
vaccines here's the new narrative and
i'm like how did how did we shift in
three months
dramatically on whatever the narrative
is currently i will not be gaslit sorry
i don't care and so i think what happens
when you have people like this woman she
goes insane i mean granted she was on
meds got off her meds that i get but
there are a lot of people like this that
are angry and insane and it's because
how do you vent your frustrations with
an ever-changing
world
you you have a world view but it's not
solidified because people keep changing
and lying i think yuri besmanov talks
about this demoralization about
eventually people are just like i can't
tell what's real anymore because the
news is changing what they said a month
ago and then they
then they drive a car through a
checkpoint screaming and dancing and
making obscene gestures because they're
just their brains erupt yep in a sick
society mental illness is a byproduct of
it and someone uh said today and i
tweeted this officially saying that the
bankers will ensure that we stay in debt
the pharmaceutical companies will ensure
that we stay sick the weapons
manufacturers will ensure that we keep
going to war the media will ensure we
are prevented from knowing the truth the
government will ensure all of this is
done legally and i think we're living in
this kind of society that has almost
every step that people take in it set
for them as a trap that benefits only
the ruling elites and creates mass human
suffering for everyone else sorry i cut
you off karen that's okay now just to
speak to the gaslighting especially when
it comes to the media let's just say
let's just say that everything they
report now is completely accurate and
true and vetted and they're being
completely honest even then
given their decades if not longer track
record of blatantly lying of blatantly
peddling government narratives you still
like how are you going to be angry at
someone for not trusting them even if
they were telling the truth right now
because of the history how could you
possibly shame someone for having
hesitations i think it's because
you're showing that you're free
you've exited the cave where the
silhouettes are dancing and some of
these people are aware they're being
lied to and they don't have the courage
to do what you've done so they would
rather stand with the mob and say no
right crabs in a bucket they're going to
pull you back in attack you but i'll
tell you this man i don't i don't
remember the exact quote from breitbart
that i've that has been brought up
several times something about like you
know go towards the fire on the other
side is freedom it was something like
that yeah i remember exactly but what i
was told it was explained to me is that
everybody is standing around and there's
this wall of fire they're terrified and
they're told by one around you don't go
near it it's bad and some people say i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna run and jump through
it and on the other side it's a party
it's a beach there's the ocean there's
food and they're like you made it out
congratulations and on the other side is
freedom and there are people trapped
inside scared to come out and find that
yo man
it's freeing right the funny thing about
this there was this post that went viral
during the during trump's first campaign
and it was someone took
a coming out story about a guy who was
gay
and they changed gay to trump supporter
and it was funny because it went viral
all the trump supporters were like wow
this resonates with me because the
person was saying things like i wasn't
being true to myself i was hiding who i
was i was scared that if i told people
the truth about what i thought and what
i felt they would attack me and they
would smear me and then it ended up
getting picked up because trump
supporters resonated with it when it was
applied to their views
i think that was a a big thing that the
internet helped to make it's one of the
reasons why censorship is so big it's
one of the reasons why they're trying to
ban everybody because community is
important to tell you
when you hear that voice on the other
side of the wall of flame telling you
hey man we're all chilling it's fine
just just jump through and like we're
partying and then people go for it and
they're like this is so much better i
don't have to freak out
it's not confusing anymore i don't have
to worry about those people being
attacked there's a community they'll
support we will support each other but
for the people who are trapped inside
the matrix it's terrifying interesting
this your metaphor goes right up along
mine whereas if the government was like
an abusive father in a relationship and
like beating up the kids you and your
siblings and then one night there's a
fire in the house and the dad's like
come on we gotta get out we gotta get
out and you're like no i don't trust you
you've been abusive and your siblings
like dude
it's an emergency covet in this in this
metaphor that's an emergency we have to
listen to the abusive guy even though we
don't want to because he's the authority
but then you realize the flames aren't
hot i mean that's along with your
metaphor it's an elusive emer
well this needs to be an elusive
emergency and this
it's a difficult analogy i mean i think
covet is nasty right i know it is nasty
but yeah the reaction of it is insane
really exactly
nasty man yeah ian and i had had kovid
uh uh like comparably bad yeah he almost
died both of you well i answered
you know we were both it was too early
to tell yeah four days in of no
treatment and i was like i'm ready to
try something how to do something i was
i called the hospital yeah that's how
bad i had and i'm like it's it's
seriously bad but you're right the
response has been insane but more
importantly
i'm i'm reading the media narratives on
social media and it's just i'm sorry man
people are
insane
they're insane i'm sorry
if you know that the narrative is bunk
on a lot of this stuff
on policy especially on mandates but you
keep just agreeing with whatever it is
fauci says next even though if we were
to play every sound bite from every
interview it would be the most
nonsensical garbage you've ever heard if
you're gonna go along with that you are
willfully lying you are nuts yeah so i
was talking about this on the way home
last night and we came up with the
conclusion that it's probably that they
have too much sunk into this this is
very much a sunk cost fallacy
application because they've wrapped
their whole identity into following the
leader and to i guess for lack of a
better expression following this mass
formation psychosis thing where they
have one leader it's very scary it's
very much crisis in leviathan where they
have this big terrifying emergency and
this lovely government leadership is
going to come and show them exactly what
to do they don't really have because
they lack community they lack their
families they lack their churches
whatever it used to be they're like i
have to follow someone i don't really
even have any friends which i think is
part of the reason that they need some
form of
therapy even when they may not
necessarily just because they lack
friends in any kind of social life
um and they end up being like okay i
can't change my views i have too much
invested in this i can't change my mind
has to be true or else what am i
standing for
well if you've if you've invested years
into this right and now
you know you're starting to recognize
that fauci has flip-flopped every day
non-stop
i feel like people's brains are just
like at this point just a mishmash of
broken
broken reality i get like war weariness
um from the insanity of 25 21 years of
conquest of war and pharmaceuticals
making people psychotic i'm interested
in to know your perspective perception
on this over the last i don't know how
long you were with ana media like a
decade ago right um
i started 2014 and we were abandoned
in journalism before that no
what was your observation of people
going if you i don't even know if you
think people have gone crazy but
people's mental state over the last
decade yeah you know i think there's
always been issues i don't i think the
people really losing it now it didn't
just come out of nowhere they probably
already had
struggles and things they were dealing
with and then it became much more
exacerbated like i think if you're a
generally well-grounded person which i
don't know i don't know how common that
is but i think in general if you have
inner resources
you might be frustrated you might be
scared but i don't think you can go to
the
to the spirals some people have fallen
into because i really see
it gets to the point where people are i
mean
you can cite cdc data and people will
still tell you you're crazy and you're
selfish and you're propagandized and
you're literally citing their authority
and they'll still they just can't even
register for that stephen crowder got a
strike on youtube for citing the cdc
right and so we we've talked about that
when it comes to uh the modern vaccine
narrative i'm just like i don't even
know what youtube's rules are at this
point because i listen to dr fauci and
i'm like well if i say that youtube bans
us because youtube says you can't say
that but fauci's saying it so i'm like i
don't even know at this point the
pressure is reaching that point where
you know we're saying like listen
we want to be reasonable people we want
to talk about what's going on but when
youtube outright says you can't discuss
things that they themselves discuss or
cnn discusses they give crowder a strike
over it i'm like yo you're asking for
people for their brains to just explode
because you're backing people into a
corner and sooner or later they're going
to say i'm mad as hell and i'm not going
to take it anymore yep
it's true it's like
giving a if if youtube were i don't like
the metaphor sword fight but if youtube
and then they give you like a plastic
sword because you're not allowed to say
the stuff they say
so like how fun is that i mean it's
life-threatening so i'm not gonna play
sorry michael knowles made the
observation the other day that it
doesn't matter what you say it matters
who says it right right stephen crowder
says it he's gone fauci says it he's
fine it doesn't matter anyway bill gates
yeah exact doctor yeah
rogan
like i saw somebody get banned i think
carl benjamin off of somebody else's so
like what will happen is that rather
than target the channel that makes the
bannable offense they target the
individual that started the channel so
then if they start a new channel with a
completely different theme
they'll whack a mole it doesn't make any
sense the channel hasn't banned any
terms and conditions thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you